Joker the much-anticipated new take on
the DC Comics villain of the same name
we've such a winding narrative that
leaves behind plenty of fascinating
implications and huge questions after
the credits roll spoilers ahead let's
get this one out of the way first
arthur fleck spends a lot of time lost
in fantasy we see this almost
immediately in the film when he's
watching Murray Franklin and fantasizes
about being an audience member who gets
called down in front of the cameras
later this goes even further when we
realized that Arthur has imagined an
entire romantic relationship with his
neighbor Sophie this tendency towards
fantasy coupled with things like the
dreamlike way he walks out of the
interview room and the final shot of the
film are enough to make us wonder how
much of the story takes place in
Arthur's head we know for sure that some
elements are imagined but what else
might be did he ever actually make it
out of that cop car in the middle of the
riot did he actually kill his therapist
was he even perhaps in the asylum the
whole time it's hard to be certain but
the rest of these questions rely on at
least some of these events being true
Arthur flex life is unraveling from
pretty much the moment Joker begins but
things only get worse when he learns
that his mother penny believes that
Thomas Wayne her former employer is
Arthur's father at first Arthur has no
reason to believe his mother is wrong
but when he confronts Wayne about it the
billionaire insists that penny is just
delusional later Arthur recovers
paperwork from Arkham State Hospital
that apparently confirms that he was
adopted but is that the whole story even
later in the film he finds a photograph
of his mother that Thomas Wayne
apparently inscribed on the back of with
a comment about Penny's lovely smile so
how much of the Wayne's story was really
true Joker is a film that keeps most of
it's very precise focus on Arthur Fleck
and his very small life but he's
accidentally a catalyst for a much
larger picture
he tells Murray Franklin that he doesn't
consider himself political but the
subway murders he commits spark a
sweeping political movement and by the
end of the film that movement considers
him to be its leader cheering at his
feet in the streets of a burning Gotham
while
de facto joker gang was founded on anti
rich sentiment amid worsening conditions
for the working class in Gotham City by
the end of the film their protests have
turned into full-on riots this begs the
question are they ever actually able to
achieve anything does the murder of
someone as important as thomas wayne
drive them back into the shadows or do
they become more active than ever a key
subplot and joker follows Thomas Waynes
campaign to become the mayor of Gotham
City and his criticisms of the
demonstrators who revere the subway
shooter Wayne is portrayed in the film
as a powerful blustery man who happens
to be sitting atop the powder keg that
is Gotham City politics and he's more
than just a little oblivious to the
lives of the less fortunate but no
matter how out of touch Thomas Wayne is
why on earth would he take his wife and
young son to a movie theater in the
middle of Gotham on the night of a plant
protest against the rich and even if he
did want to take that risk why didn't he
at least have a driver waiting to escort
them out whether courageous or just
clueless it seems like a really bad time
to go to the movies when you've got a
perfectly good mansion - chilling there
have been many similar versions of
Batman's origin story but they all
involve the death of Bruce Wayne's
parents whether they're gunned down by a
random mugger or a guy specifically
named Joe Chill or Jack Napier in Joker
the Wayne's are killed by a random clown
masked rider who happens to have a gun
but there's no way Bruce Wayne won't
later learn that the whole ordeal
happened because of Arthur Fleck with
that in mind is Batman's eventual
mission to fight crime cast in a
different light it's no longer just
crime that killed his parents
it's the violent movement surrounding
Joker in this world does Bruce Wayne's
still become Batman or does his mission
change will he focus on Arthur Fleck
exclusively and if he does become Batman
how does knowing what he knows about
Arthur change him
Arthur Fleck is at first reluctant to
embrace the violence within him but by
the end of Joker the dam is clearly
broken
I'm negative Arthur is no longer
interested in holding himself back from
killing Murray Franklin on live TV to
murdering the therapist interviewing him
at Arkham
as the film ends Arthur's potential
escape is left up in the air because
he's the Joker now we can reasonably
assume that he did manage to get out of
Arkham that day and is on the loose
again after the credits roll if that
happened what's his purpose now who does
he go after next
his mother's old abusive boyfriend or
his birth parents or will he become like
the comic book version of the Joker and
simply act as an agent of chaos pursuing
random bloodshed whatever he does it
won't be pretty
Gotham City is a metropolis teetering on
the brink even before Arthur phlex
rampage it's dirty covered in graffiti
and mountains of garbage are piling up
amid a strike while super rats stalk the
darker parts of town
it's a city infested with crime
unemployment and anger
the rise of Arthur and those who
sympathize with him only makes things
worse it all seems to culminate in the
murders of Thomas Wayne and Murray
Franklin but surely that's not where it
ends with Thomas Wayne dead the divide
between the privileged and the
underprivileged in Gotham could deepen
very quickly the police could crack down
even harder on people who don't deserve
it and the Joker gang could respond with
even bigger more violent riots the city
is on edge and it won't have that man to
come to the rescue for at least another
decade so what does Gotham do how does
it cope there's no easy answer check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]